Chân báo nhân dân định từ ngày 2018, phóng viên báo nhân dân đã có cuộc chào đổi với nhà báo phạm phủ phục
Mên phó trường bàn biên tập tình thế giới thông tình xa Việt Nam. Chân dạ phần tích các phần đề cuộc tế về nguyên nhân
dễn biến và hay luyện từ kăng thằng giữ sơ lên và ira thiền này. Nhà phần tích phạm phủ phục cho rằng
lịch sửi sơ lên ira và cá Mỹ từng có có thể tốt đẹp từ khi sơ lên thành lập nhận nước, và nó mừng gần chi trăm 1 tám,
cho nên năm 2018, tuy nhiên quan hệ dưới bà biên bắt đầu dẫn, sau khi mạnh hồi giá ấu tại ira năm 2018,
giám tính nhiều lệ của Mỹ và đồng Mỹ sơ lên tại ira, bị giám đoạn hoặc sóa bỏ.
Tìm chẳng đối đầu, giờ các bên tiếp tục kéo dài trong nhiều năm với những hành động đáp trả lên nhau,
giờ Mỹ và đồng Mỹ sơ lên với ira. Đình điểm chính là các chính dịch quân sự chức tiếp bùng phát sửi sơ lên và ira,
người thiệt hạnh lớn về cửa xe hạ tăng, nhân mạng cho các hay bên.
Gũng theo hông phạm phục phúc, lý giói sơ lên có thể tấn công các mục tiêu trên lãnh tổ gí raan với độ chính xác cao,
ngoài việc sửiếu các loại vụ khí hình đại, chính là hay thống tình báo của độ báo phủ xong rau bên trong lãnh tổ gí raan.
Sức tham gia của Mỹ với việc tấn công báo cơ sản nhân chọn yếu của ira, báo sáng sớm ngày 2020,
nhiều một sự tiếp sức đáng kẻ chủi sơ lên. Theo hông phục, không loại chưa khả năng quá sình tương thực hiện các đòn tấn công kết theo,
tâm chỉ với cường độ lớn hơn, và tương độ nhàng hơn, như ira n con những hành động trả đua, nhắm vào các lấy cút loại của Mỹ ở cúb cực.
Về hệ qua, ngoài tất cả đồng trực tiếp tới cả ira và yên xa raan, xung đột leo thang của thế kiến kinh tiét hoàn cao cũng sẽ chíu tác lận tiêu cực nghiêm trọng,
nặc biệt là chủi cùng gứng đăng lợp, sẽ bị gián đoạn, kéo thao hệ luy tên lãnh dọc, lối với đình kinh tiê thi giới.
Về hệ bình cạnh đỏ qua đẻ dựa các cúc ra trong khu vực cũng nhiều dựa các nước lớn với tình nước tại khu vực trung đồng có thể sẽ chờ nên phức tập và khó kìm xuất hơn.
Chúng nghĩa khu vô vốn tạm lắng trong vải đăng qua của Mỹ cơ tài đủng phát, lấy dụng bất oon để mở dụng phát đồng từ đó để gió nghiêm trọng đến ăn đình kinh tiê khu vực và cú tế.